Vielleicht kennt der ein oder andere von euch den untersberg bei beuys garten am alpenrand ein ganz besonderer berg
Wenn man den zahlreichen sagen und mythen glauben schenken
Mag in den meisten erzählungen geht es um zeit löcher oder spiegel welten die naturkräfte
Hier sollen anders ticken, als wir es ansonsten kennen doch, was genau steckt hinter dem spuk
Ihr habt euch dieses mysteriöse thema bei whatsapp gewünschte bekommt jetzt alle wichtigen facts zum sogenannten
wunderwerk am alpenrand, danke für eure themenvorschlag und herzlich willkommen bei klicks um science and fidget und
Wir jetzt übrigens auch zusätzlich mit telegramm inserm facebook natürlich wie bisher auch mit whatsapp dabei sein können das erfahrt ihr am ende des videos
Es gibt so einige mysteriöse orte auf dieser welt beispielsweise das bermuda dreieck im atlantik dort sollen sich flugzeuge
Und schiffe einfach so in luft auflösen auch aber auch am untersberg in der nähe von bestes gaben
Sollen menschen immer mal wieder auf unerklärliche art und weise verschwinden beispielsweise soll mal ein jäger ein ganzes jahr
Verschwunden gewesen sein um dann zu seinem eigenen trauer gottesdienst wieder aufzutauchen
Oder aber die sage nach der sich mitte august immer wieder eine geheime stelle
Des berges öffnen soll ein zeitloch das in eine spiegel welt führt darin lebt
Der mythos nach seit bereits 1000 jahren kaiser karl
Der große und herrscht über zwerge adlige und ritter die zeit in den höhlen des berges soll
300 mal langsamer vorbeigehen als in der realen welt, außerdem erzählt man sich auch die sage der sogenannten
Untersberg aus einer anderen welt sie tauchen einfach so im hier und jetzt auf
Beispielsweise in den 14 kirchen des untersberg so erzählt es die legende eines baumes der bei einem
Gottesdienstbesuch es erstaunt war
Dass er niemand der anderen besucher erkannte kein wunder denn es handelte sich bei den fremden leuten um die
untersberg klar
Aber es sind nicht nur die sagen und mythen die den untersberg als einen ganz besonderen berg mit zeit löchern und spiegel welt
Auf beschwerden die einwohner der region nennen ihn den wunder berg und der dalai lama selbst
Bezeichnet ihn als herz chakra von europa, es könnte, also wirklich etwas dran sein
Wenn man das hört dabei ist der untersberg auch geografisch gesehen nicht zu verachten er ist
1972 meter hoch sein gebirgszug erstreckt sich auf 70
Quadratkilometer und der untersberg ist nicht zuletzt auch für das längste höhlensystem deutschlands bekannt
Zwei drittel des untersberg liegen in bayern, die grenze zu österreich verläuft durch seinen nördlichen teil
Der fakt ist gefühlt lebt
Die gesamte region dort von angeblichen wundern und besonderen energiefeldern am untersberg nirgendwo
Sonst in oberbayern sind wohl so viele esoteriker unterwegs
Wie hier einige sind als alten schamane unterwegs und machen führungen sie glauben daran
Dass der untersberg eine art prophet für die restliche welt ist so habe es beispielsweise als eine vorwarnung für das schwere himalaya
Erdbeben auch am untersberg einen absturz gegeben zudem
Hatte sich durch das geröll das wasser des angrenzenden weiß bares rot gefärbt auch das ein zeichen
Ebenso, wie kurz vor beginn des zweiten weltkriegs
Als ich hier in der region, der himmel rot gefärbt hatte nach ansicht der esoteriker vor ort eine prophezeiung
Darauf, dass der russlandfeldzug
Blutig enden wird die allumfassende erklärung der esoteriker auf
Der erde sei alles mit allem verbunden und der untersberg gebe das wieder was auf der anderen seite
Der welt passiert und in dieser region des berchtesgadener landes
Sind es nicht gerade wenige leute die an solche theorien glauben und daran festhalten an zufälle glaubt hier keiner
Ebenso wenig, was die unfälle von höhlenforschern angeht im jahr 2014 wurde ein bekannter
Höhlenforscher in 950 metern tiefe von einem stein am kopf getroffen
Seine rettung war durchaus spektakulär sie dauerte und neun tage und der forscher überlebte
Tatsächlich, das ist für viele ein wunder und schicksal ist dann der zweite unfall fast exakt ein jahr später
Da wurde nämlich eine der leiterinnen von einem stein erschlagen
Viele denken
Dies liege an dem vorherigen ereignis das energetische spuren hinterlassen habe und schließlich wusste doch jeder
Dass man den dauerkonflikten auf gar keinen fall betreten sollte, es gibt sogar ein buch autor
Der eine buchreihe veröffentlicht hat eine ganze buchreihe gefüllt mit wunderlichen geschichten zum untersberg
Wolfgang stadler hat seiner ansicht nach schon selbst, die wunder des untersberg verfahren
Beispielsweise war selbst schon einmal in einem zeit noch gefangen so sagt
Der vormittags hatte er eine höhle einen besuch abgestattet, als er wieder rauskam war es plötzlich abend und auch dunkel
Der berg ist für ihn eine riesige zeitmaschine dazu stadler in einem interview zitat
Ich bin ein gelernter techniker und glaube nur was ich sehen kann
Mittlerweile habe ich aber soviel unfassbares erlebt, dass ich völlig offen, bin für alles mystische
Seine lesung, jedenfalls sind super besucht und stadler ist überzeugt davon
Dass seine geschichten wahr sind und so seit mittlerweile auch der geheimdienst hinter ihm her
Jetzt wird es
Aber sagen wir mal etwas seltsam fest steht jedenfalls
Die oft gruselig anmutenden geschichten vom verschwundenen menschen haben sehr oft ganz einfache gründe
Beispielsweise waren in den 90er jahren mal ein ehepaar und eine freundin, als vermisst gemeldet worden
Sie sollen in ein zeitloch gefallen sein so die befürchtung am ende stellte sich dann heraus
Dass sie niemals am untersberg war sondern auf einem schiff im roten meer dazu kommt
Forschungsteams weltweit halten zeit löcher auf, der erde die in anderen dimensionen führen für komplett, abwegig es scheint
Also, alles ein wenig
Unterirdisch zu sein, also abwegig, was so über den untersberg erzählt, sorry, wenn ich da enttäuschen muss
Wenn er als erstes neues zu mythen und geheimnissen und zu allen anderen themen erfahren wollt
Dann endet meine telefonnummer hierbei whatsapp oder den anderen messengern, wie instagram facebook oder telegramm
Dann erfahrt ihr von mir vor allen anderen vom neuesten video
Garantiert und täglich ihr könnt dort direkt über mich in der redaktion von klicks und mitmachen mitbestimmen
Was ihr bei pixum passiert und zur begrüßung gibt es noch ein kleines goodie einfach hier draufklicken und natürlich nicht das abo mit der
Genau mit der glocke vergessen, hier geht es weiter mit darf auch draufklicken mythen legenden und spekulationen, die acht spannenden pyramiden fakten
Sonst bis dann
Bleibt dran?